you suited up and booted up you know
what they say if you look good you feel
good you do good and here we go the
clash between magnus carlsen and
pragnanda and magnus starts with white
he opens with the king's pawn and it's
the sicilian defense so pragnanda not
playing a solid line here not showing
any fear in the opening what will magnus
do will he take prague on in a real main
line he brings his night out i'm hoping
for an open sicilian here
and uh okay it's not an open sicilian
it's what we call the rossolimo
variation where white bishop comes out
to put some pressure on black's knight
and actually we're more used to seeing
magnus on the black side of this
position magnus is the world leading
expert on this position as black so uh
prague using the world champion's
weapons against him a really interesting
start ah
so pragmata he has his second here his
coach actually ramesh and what do you
think about their preparation the
openings that prague has played so far
in the tournament his openings have been
good they've suited him he has been in
trouble in a few games
towards the end of the opening towards
the middle game but he's able to kind of
work his way through that just keep
fighting and
he's not going for anything too dull too
dry
i think
okay he's got great understanding great
strategic play prague but he's happy to
kind of fight fire with fire and take
those risks uh which have paid off so
far so um it's
yeah i'm slightly surprised by the
opening strategy magnus knows everything
there is to know about this opening
pretty much
but maybe it's a psychological thing
just saying okay i know you know this
stuff but uh let's
uh let's fight pregnant clearly thinks
he can match magnus
in terms of homework and magnus of
course had that one creative one f3
happening has he played some more
creative openings or has he gone back to
the normal after that well so far that's
been a one-off okay and we haven't seen
the likes of that again but i am looking
forward to maybe a potential surprise i
have a suspicion it might happen if
magnus is feeling confident or he's
feeling in a good mood
and uh well the hoodie is off yeah okay
maybe he's feeling better today he's
been super cold he's been sick
so now warm today that's a good sign
yeah yesterday he clearly felt a lot
better magnus beating anishigiri really
convincingly we've got to say
so magnus clearly back to his best in
the mood at least and i mean it's it's
not hard to get motivated when you're
playing against uh someone on a hot
streak like prague uh i know that
whenever i play younger players i want
to show them who's boss you know you
want to show them you know respect your
elders and everything so magnus he'll be
focused he'll want to win this match uh
prague meanwhile the first to really
think
and uh this last move by magnus we
should say not the most popular just
pushing a pawn one square it's not the
most ambitious but simon uh what do you
think of this opening choice by prague
yeah i think it's quite interesting i
mean
as you said this is uh magnus's
speciality and he's playing it um so
kind of magnus is playing against his
own opening uh and that's sometimes
quite hard hard to do because you have
to adjust and
even though you know it incredibly well
suddenly the shoes on the other foot
um and i think here magnus with his last
move is just indicating that he wants to
play chess
and what that means is he doesn't want
to get involved with any theoretical
discussion any theory in depth theory he
just wants to get a position with all
the pieces on the board which he can
play a little cough there from magnus
but i think in in general he's looking a
lot fresher today um and as kai said
just taking his top off
and getting the t-shirt is is is a good
sign because he he was very ill and he
kept you know he kept being warm so i
think this is good it's a good start
yeah
yeah when we saw him walking towards the
arena magnus there was a bit more of a
spring and step than previous days where
he was really clearly visibly uh not
wanting to be there so
um okay big matchup and prague i'm
slightly surprised he's thinking because
this move despite the fact it's rarer
than some alternatives it is known
and uh he's just deciding is black's
night the knight that hasn't been
developed is that going to come out is
black going to push a pawn if so which
pawn to push
okay prague yet to click on a piece we
see a screen there very focused
prague he's won a lot of games from
difficult positions but he's been low on
time in several of them so
maybe that's something magnus wants to
target his previous opponents haven't
been able to take advantage of that but
prague yeah one maybe small
kind of thing that he still needs to
work on is his time management time
management yeah now we do see them
sitting and especially prague he's quite
small of size as well not only age
sitting behind that computer it's a big
computer do you think that is an
advantage when you play against magnus
to actually play online chess in the
arena with this big computer so you
don't actually see him
right the mug is a little ugly
oh no no
no no
no
i'm
you know in over the board you just you
look right at him and you get that
psychological magnus effect you might
get more intimidated definitely because
he's the world champion you're like you
suddenly have a reality check and you're
like i'm a school kid i'm playing the
world champion
what's happening it could be
i think it might help you know just
having the barrier there so he can
properly focus on the chest and not on
other aspects yeah having said that they
did start off the game with a handshake
yeah they did that was very nice it was
very very nice to see but not all the
players have done that a lot of them
have kind of just nodded their head in
greeting here maybe
magnus wanting
to make his presence known
because you know magnus you know we've
seen him be the expert when it comes to
mind games exactly
his opponent we've had a few examples in
this tournament right yeah uh i mean one
f3 comes to mind the mind games just
saying to duda in in the first game
of the tournament just saying okay i can
do anything and i can still beat you
magnus loves to show his dominance i
mean it's it's very much kind of animal
kingdom instinct you want to show your
opponent you know i'm the i'm the boss
i'm the king of the jungle but uh yeah
that handshake i just wonder who was the
firmer of the two who wanted to kind of
make eye contact and say okay this is my
day
it's really a strange thing when you
shake hands because uh
i always have this opinion
shaking hands with loads of chess
players and if they give you the wet
fish
if they just put it out like that and
they're like you know they look the
other way you're like right i'm gonna
crush you now because i want a proper
handshake i don't want him to like you
know just literally dangle it there
sweaty palm or something and it's like
oh god and but if they give you a proper
handshake i think it's a bit more
respectful in some ways so really that's
a you know just a little small
thing about you know gentlemen play i
guess yeah
it's a general rule right when you're
applying for a job for example or you're
meeting new people firm handshake
everyone it's there's the best way to
introduce yourself and eye contact and
eye contact yep i agree and definitely
don't crunch your opponent's hand that's
a bad sign ah you know you need no
fishes and no crunching yeah the mid
somewhere in this
firm handshake and like david says smile
and eye contact and we see a trade
and definitely one of white's choices
there were other alternatives but uh
very committal stuff from magnus and now
the big question is which pawn are you
going to recapture with and uh prague
chooses to recapture with the queen's
pawn
and i guess this would be more familiar
territory for prague yeah he's playing
like magnus isn't he i mean isn't this
following the the world championships
fabiano you know fabiano versus magnus
this exact position
pretty much i think just maybe
a small change in move order uh and i
think white was not committing the king
so early in those games but either way
this exact pawn structure as you say
simon uh it happened in that 2018 world
championship match and this has been
very deeply studied clearly by carlson
but by a lot of top ground masters when
i was young i was playing this kind of
bishop b5 opening very
regularly and
it would pretty much always end up in
this pawn structure so okay here we go
magnus as the expert bringing his rook
towards the center
uh i'm slightly surprised to see that
one usually we see white maybe developer
knight bring a pawn out at some point
develop the dark square bishop but uh
magnus just staying flexible and he's
gone for a slower game and that's
noticeable magnus class and he's just
going for a slow strategic approach
prague now is he going to castle the
black king is he going to move the black
knight again lots and lots of choice but
that's interesting that both players
despite the fact it's a relatively known
type of position both players have
invested a few minutes already
it's clearly a lot of mutual respect and
uh clearly both players just trying to
figure out what type of pawn structure
they want what type of position they
want prague does keep his king safe now
by castling yeah i'm kind of a bit
intrigued by this rook move that magnus
has played because i've kind of whenever
i played this opening with the white
pieces i mean it was a long long time
ago but i
kept that rook on its original square
just because i was preparing a pawn
break and now
um whoa i'm curious to see what kind of
plan he has is it to push his king's
pawn one square further or does he have
anything else up his sleeve yeah i think
that's uh the idea your bank is very
concrete so as you mentioned white's
pawn can go further but normally black
wants to stop that black can't push his
pawn in the center right now because it
just gets captured it's not a safe pawn
push but if black prepares it the usual
move here is actually to retreat the
knight but then in before you allow
black to stake a claim in the center i
think magnus's idea is to push forward
so that's why his position is rook here
his knight here he wants to start
attacking by pushing forward and prague
has just tried to initiate a similar
idea bringing his queen to the side
trying to cover this square it's all
about whether black can push forward if
white pushes forward now then at least
the black knight gets a nice square in
the center of the board so just some
small strategy and magnus has done it
we're going to see this pawn may be
trying to
kind of cut the board in half and magnus
is going to try later to start attacking
the black king let's go back to the
players it's
already heating up after this last move
yeah i'm i'm a major fan as you know
from some of the other rounds are
getting the pawn the white pawn that
magnus has got to that square in general
because it normally when you get the
pawn there indicates that white is going
to go for a kingside attack because you
take away that knight from its defensive
role around the black king it is has to
move away from the king and as david
said you can start attacking those dark
squares generally by uh bringing out
your dark square bishop and the queen
maybe tucked in behind it and things
like that so uh of course very early
days um but i kind of like what magnus
has done so far um it makes a lot of
sense to me finishing his development
now
yep so a nice move there just bringing
his knight forward the knight might be
destined for the center it might be
destined for this side of the board lots
of uh flexibility for white let's go
back to the players
it's uh yeah i'm very optimistic now
that we're going to see a full blooded
fight
and uh how the styles are up against
each other here um magnus universal
style he can play any type of position
more known maybe for his end games but
yeah he can do anything uh prague
very very good in the end game for
someone so young he's maybe the
exception to the rule normally
youngsters
they hate the end games they want to win
by checkmate they just go for the attack
prague
he's happy to just grind people down
even when he was 12 years old he was
already a grandmaster but he beat me in
an end game
i just assumed i'd swap the pieces off
grind him down use my superior
understanding but nope it didn't work
uh he's already been he's always been
very good at the end game but lately
he's become sharp i think that's
something he's working on with ramesh uh
slightly more dynamic slightly more
aggressive so he's trying to kind of uh
become the universal player that magnus
is thinking well maybe we should bring
up the aim chess stats because we do
have
uh the aimches dats that sort of
measures online uh all the online games
and one of the factors is actually end
games oh wow look at that
he's much better than magnus in the end
game according to the stats yeah we
should mention that these aim chess
stats for magnus they're based on the
meltwater champions chess tour but
prague last year he also played on the
uh julius bear challengers tour so he
played slightly lower opposition in some
of these games that's why he won 71 of
his end games but nevertheless that
those are impressive stats
and or yeah also advantage
capitalization very very high for prague
meaning what is advantage capitalization
so when the evaluation bar gives you a
decent advantage a decisive advantage he
wins those games more often than not and
uh yeah even more ruthless there than
magnus i don't think anyone can claim
that he's better than magnus in the
ending i'm sorry but you can't claim
that you can't say the 16 year old is
better than the end game which is well
very very good yeah he's very good but
he's not better than magnus yes yeah so
like david said based on uh games
against lower rated players for prague
than for magnus but
uh the point still being that at a very
young age he is uh extremely good at the
end game yeah he absolutely is and as
those statistics showed you know on the
julius chess challenge you know he won
71 of the endgame
so that's a very very impressive
statistic
so i mean also he's such a hard worker i
mean he's been playing chess and
studying chess most of his life and his
whole life at the present moment
is revolving around the game you know
he's studying almost full time although
he does attend school as he told me
exactly because we do have and this is
interesting you guys the next chess talk
with ivanka will be released tomorrow
and it is an in-depth talk with young
pregnant super interesting that will be
released to all chess 24 premium members
tomorrow on uh chat24.com and collection
already the chess talk with liam lee is
out there but tomorrow pregnant on that
that's gonna be interesting yeah it
definitely is you know because you kind
of get an insight into what drives
pragananda what his life is like you
know because we're all kind of curious
what is his life you know what was it
like during covert times what was it
like on the road
and what does he do with every single
part of his day and he's he gives a very
frank and honest answer and uh yeah we
see you we see why he's so good
basically and uh yeah uh i liked uh i
liked what he responded when i asked him
his favorites because i was a bit
shocked to find out he was still at
school i'm looking forward to that yeah
yeah and remember also so this is
exclusive to chess 24 premium members
but right now if you use the code on the
bottom of the screen uh esports cup you
get 40
of chess 24 premium so great chance now
to get that discount and to watch the
chess talks and
special video editions of all the
podcasts a niche geary podcast is
released today and that's a good one
it's in two parts actually because you
talked for two hours yeah
that was a long chat with anish geary
and he was very frank as well uh all of
these top players actually very very
honest and open about their lifestyles
and of course we touched on some very
sensitive topics as well like the
twitter hacking and
yeah we just talked about what anish has
been up to the last few years it's been
an eventful time for him yeah so that is
available right now on chess24.com and
if you click the collection tab you'll
find that podcast video edition with
nishkiri now i did hear a move what's
happening now in this game yeah so
prague has entered the white half of the
board with his knights that knight looks
nicely poised for a potential attack but
the black knight is a bit of a lone wolf
right now uh not really teaming up with
the rest of black's army so i think
actually the uh kind of ulterior motive
uh the real reason prague has planted
his knight on this square is because he
wants to retreat at some point and
blockade white's far advanced pawn in
the middle meanwhile magnus isn't
worried about this night jump he was
just choosing his tunes there choosing
his music
and yeah i'm expecting white's knight in
front of the white queen to jump out the
way it just depends which side of the
board magnus wants to go to
and at some point the black knight will
have to retreat uh a nice square i think
it's headed to but it's a bit time
consuming
yeah i mean it's trying to come around
to the center um i would thought
magnus's simple plan will still be to
try and uh start an attack against
black's king side maybe go for the
exchange of dark square bishops um but i
mean this move surprised me a lot
actually i i didn't see the see this
move in advance but it's it's kind of
positionally founded and again showing
quite a lot of majority i think from uh
you know a player so young still so
young so
um but i i guess magnus really as you
mentioned earlier he really wants to win
these games like when he's playing these
potential future world champions he's
mentioned about the the candidates um
he'll play ali raza another person that
people are saying is going to be a
future world champion and it's kind of
the same with prague people are saying
this this kid's going to be the future
world champion i think he's the kind of
players he wants to like
really you know he's really excited to
play he really you know really maybe
even ups his game to play um because
again it's maybe showing that dominance
isn't it in some respects and saying
yeah you come on you've got a long way
to go yet
so uh i think he's going to be really up
for this one
is there so we talk about he's only 16
and we talk about him as a future world
champion has there been players around
that age
that people have said oh he's going to
be a future world champion that sort of
haven't lived up to it maybe yet or or
they've all become great players yeah
but one name that springs to mind is uh
timor rajawolf you know he became a
grandmaster very quickly defeated gary
kasparov at the i think 16 years old and
everyone kind of built him as the next
world champion but it he didn't manage
that
i mean okay he has now actually he's
going to play he's going to play the
candidates so of course he can still
manage it but uh i mean obviously he's
still an incredibly strong grand
master's
and there are a few people who just they
get to the top ten but don't quite take
it to the next level it's oh speaking of
candidates yes sir something else
happened recently dingley wren
i think he is now
qualified to take that spot from sergey
karjakin who is uh banned by fidei yeah
i think karyakin is launching an appeal
or the russian federation is launching
an appeal on his behalf but um assuming
that
the kind of ban doesn't get overturned
it looks like ding is in he's kind of
the sufficient number of games he needed
to play i think it was 26 games in a
month wow and he's i think he's played
28 games uh in the last month or so it's
just i mean he's been on the ramp we're
not talking rapid games classical games
long long games some of his games
lasting five six hours and so it's kind
of kind of manufactured that he got in
the into the candidates basically it's a
controversial would you say it's a bit
controversial yeah yeah i mean it's
within the rules yeah
i mean he's he should be there really
because he's one of the strongest
players he deserves to be there he is
now world number two right and yeah
exactly he certainly is now after after
all these games
i'm surprised he didn't overtake magnus
to be totally honest but um but that
would have been controversial i guess
though yeah i mean it would have been um
but i mean he's he he should be there
because he's one of the best players
it's just how he got there was a little
bit strange i think it's fair china
organized the chinese chess federation
organized some sort of marathon
tournament for him to play those 27
games yeah i mean me and david are
planning something similar actually
we're gonna start with that start the
day after this tournament and in two
years time when you when you beat me 200
nil
you'd be well number two
it was very strange actually the number
of games it happened over three
different events but
uh i mean none of the chinese players
had really played for the last year or
two and it was especially organized
purely for ding especially the first
tournament wasn't the strongest
opposition uh possible so
some controversy there but uh either way
he's he's gonna be the man to beat now
maybe ding in the candidates not only is
he the world number two but he's really
kind of match fit after all these games
i mean compared to maybe world number
three farouza who's just disappeared off
the map since uh since december uh i
mean ding's done the exact opposite just
playing non-stop big big move in the
game there david as well because this
this is a really committal and
brave or or
there's a fine line isn't it brave or
silly let's see yeah so black's actually
grabbed a pawn in the center of the
board but it has come at the cost of
trading off black's dart square bishop
so if we do a quick count black is one
point up but look at the black queen
oh eyed up by the white rook the black
knight really shaky white bishop kind of
attacking it it's hanging together by a
thread right now and magnus is he can i
was about to say is he gonna move his
knight to unleash an attack against the
black queen from the white rook
and now the black queen has to move and
she has to find a safe square
i think she's going to go back but which
square is she going to choose and uh
maybe he's just going to win his pawn
back here yeah
rather than try to go for the dark
squares which was another way you could
play and keep it as a pawn sacrifice but
yeah maybe we can just quickly show what
happened because because it was quite uh
a big decision by prague as you
mentioned simon so this knight is
attacked and instead of retreating it to
a safe square i was assuming that he
just jumped back we saw prague get
greedy take this pawn in the center of
the board and after a trade it's really
hanging together uh just about for black
the queen defends the knight and after
white's night move the queen does run
away to safety she was attacked by
white's rook and now after a quick trade
of pieces we see black's queen has done
a bit of dancing the last few moves but
white eventually regains the pawn so
level material again but this rook is
super strong right now on the seventh
rank keeping this black bishop tied down
to the defense of some pawns and the
dart squares around the black king are
pretty weak so if white's queen and
knight can maybe line up on those dark
squares later it's going to be dangerous
for prague
so the pressure on prague now to try and
evict this white rook if he can kick it
away and trade rooks off maybe then he's
okay i mean yeah sorry you okay i was
just going to say but wait one second i
was just looking at that rook and that
rook is loose it looks very strong and i
was like oh hang on a second is there
some radical move yeah like bishop
takes i think in the same yeah maybe
this move is is the idea yeah exactly
yeah and the whole idea is if pawn takes
bishop now then as you mentioned uh guys
this rook is loose this king is open
suddenly a double attack a check hitting
the king and hitting the rook this would
win for black so magnus must have
something up his sleeve after this
bishop capture
what is it is he uh is he just gonna get
greedy and take this pawn maybe
the white king's suddenly under some
fire under some pressure if he retreats
the rook for example attacking the black
queen then the black queen can just
slide back threatening checkmate big big
moment for prague he's calculating this
can he get away with opening up the
white king and taking this pawn or maybe
is he going to slide back with the queen
same idea just different order attacking
this rook first it's getting really
critical evaluation bar's still roughly
in the middle but it's drama on the
board wow yeah all right and the clock
is ticking for pragnanda we do have
three great englishmen in the studio to
guide us through all of these games and
all the drama
there's also an englishman out
in the lounge with you svada hi who's uh
who has arrived the oslo arena today you
know i found the best company here right
now because i i found the most
entertaining chess man i could imagine
i'm here with lauren strength and it's
it's been it's been highly entertaining
to watch this game together with him
because you're opinionated and what's
your opinion so far on this uh this game
well i i wasn't really convinced by
pragnanda's choice to give up the bishop
the darts were bishop you tend not to
want to do that even if you win a pawn
because you leave yourself very exposed
and
now we have i'm just looking at the
position
uh
what is going on here what am i missing
uh the bishop is on h3
the rook is on b7 and it's pregnant to
move yeah it just got completely crazy
all of a sudden i i turned away and this
happened uh
i don't know what to
make of this position it looks totally
unclear to me i wasn't a fan of what
pregnant did but you know it's a sign of
how these new young players play
you know 20 30 years ago they wouldn't
have played like this but now it's just
either it works or it doesn't and they
are confident and they calculate it and
they just say okay i don't care about
what uh
general chess theory says
i'm actually going to take it back to
the studio as well so you guys can
follow up on this craziness but we agree
with you this is getting uh a little
nuts and we enjoy it
definitely thank you sweater and
lawrence nice to see lauren's in the
building what's happening yeah as uh
laura said
years ago they wouldn't have played like
this because prague in a way he's broken
the rules look at those black pawns now
they're so ugly so weak on the queen
side on that left half of the board but
then again the white rook is almost
trapped the white rock lacking escape
squares and we saw a dance between the
rook and bishop that's really rare uh
kind of an odd scenario there white's
rook went to grab a pawn the black
bishop which was actually suddenly
attacked did go back to its starting
square but now white's rook
forced back into this uh kind of cage
and uh the black bishop just keeping it
locked up what do you think is this i
mean the evaluation was slightly on my
side but is this dangerous for magnus as
well because white's rook
might well just fall off the board
yeah i mean i i would have thought here
that um if the queens come off the board
uh magnus will just win it's as simple
as that in a safe way because
it's quite clear what's going on here i
think that white rook is the one thing
that's magnus's problem if that rook
could come back to
you know defer well into white's half of
the board i'm pretty sure magnus is just
doing incredibly well look at black's
pawns on the queen side we talked about
these uh weaknesses uh yesterday
and they're just ugly you've got double
pawns you've got what we call isolated
pawns arie no mates or alice no mates
over there you know all on its own so
this is why magnus is now playing this
move he'd love to exchange queens and
prague will certainly not allow that can
he get that rook if he can get that rook
it's a different ball game yeah it's
exactly what you said simon a queen
trade is going to favor white massively
so prague should not trade the queen's
off right now yeah but it's also a
sneaky move that magnus has played
because yeah you know it is offering a
queen trade but you know i'm pretty sure
that queen at the right moment has some
devilish intentions to
plant herself on the h6 square and if
she gets there and she's joined by a
knight
well there might be trouble ahead and
the queen
sidesteps and covers that square also
clever defense by pragnanda because he
attacks the rook at the same time so
this is setting up to be an absolutely
thrilling game and as always you know
it's not just us enjoying the fun and
games in the studio but you know we also
want everyone at home to be part of this
and uh to kick off the selfies um the
rick actually moves away because it was
under fire oh god the moves coming
fast and furious don't have time to get
a selfie
of course yes okay well it comes from
abhishek who says that magnus doesn't
believe in fortresses but fishy does
love all books from dan brown and
cheering for magnus so magnus with a
supporter in abhishek and remember if
you want to
join in the fun send us your selfie do
it in landscape mode then tweet us using
the hashtag chess champs and we will
feature them on the show yes let's have
as many selfies as we have moves in this
game what's happening here now yeah lots
of moves and prague with those weak
pawns i think he's done the right thing
he's traded off a couple of bones there
he's trying to open up diagonals lines
as well black's rooks and bishop might
well become very strong pieces the more
that the lines become open so i like
prague's last move
the black queen can now go across and
recapture this white pawn
but as ivanka mentioned the dark squares
around
around the black king those are a
potential weakness as well so
i mean it could go either way right now
either white's rook is very very strong
on the seventh rank or it's going to get
trapped
so it could be a strength of a weakness
and likewise with black's king position
black's king looks really safe right now
but it could well come under fire from
white's queen at night if they can
combine so uh magnus slightly smiling
yeah it's the first time we've seen him
smile isn't it during the game because
he's he's
at least ill so he's like yeah which is
nice to see
yeah why is he smiling now what do we
reckon
maybe he's looking at prague's clock
time and thinking oh i'm up on the clock
yeah it could be
meanwhile yeah black recapturing the
pawn it's level material again and
white's queen finally getting off the
first rank getting active and white's
rook in the corner now are ready to join
the action as well
and magnus is really trying to get the
queens off still i don't think so
anymore as much because
it's less clear now a queen trade
pros and cons for both sides but now
that black got rid of his set of double
pawns he traded off a set of uh weak
pawns earlier so it's less clear now and
okay a bishop for nitrate i'm really
surprised prague went for this and
magnus getting greedy magnus is going to
pawn up yeah he didn't think much about
that as well he played that incredibly
quickly grabbing that pawn i mean okay
prague's got to prove this now prague is
gone he has gone a pawn down what's his
idea here um i think he blundered
yes there's just a blunder i missed that
oh what's up for grabs his head's in his
hand so that that would well i don't
know fair wow he doesn't give much away
prague does he but uh
i can't see much compensation here i
mean it's a big pawn to take and magnus
very confident in taking it yeah you
could see on prague's face there he just
widened his eyes as if like oh what have
i done yeah and that's why the
evaluation bar says plus one for white
white is one pawn up white has a three
versus one advantage now on the left
half of the board and if the queen's
come off now it's just game over and
that's why magnus is also trying to swap
rooks off if uh if he can do that it's
gonna be very very good for him and
there we see the computer suggestions
stockfish suggestions but they're all
good for white that's the problem for
prague he plays the best move he swapped
one set of rooks but now okay he has to
win some of those white pawns the white
three there the connected three on the
left
if they survive it's just an easy win
for magnus in the end game and we saw
end game stats but if you're pawn up
it's relatively simple uh especially if
you're all your pawns are connected so
prague is desperately trying to win some
of those pawns with his queen but magnus
he can block this attack with one of his
pawns he can drop his queen back to
defend he's just got to consolidate
hasn't he i mean if magnus can um just
consolidate his position which i feel he
should bear to do you know maybe even
bring his queen back stop black
attacking his pawns he will win this
that past a pawn it is so strong
especially even with the rook behind it
the root behind it is is in a good
position you exchange queens you're
completely winning as well um so prague
has got to cause as much nuisance in the
position that you can keep attacking
things
try to get the rook in somehow but
prague's extra prawn on the king side it
doesn't really do much at the moment
that's the other thing so it really
doesn't play a part in this in this
position at all yeah harry has no rival
but it's a long time before it really
plays a part in this game as you
mentioned simon so the direct threat is
queen takes pawn we're expecting magnus
either to drop his queen back maybe to
defend it uh maybe slide his queen
across this way to defend it from the
front okay or i was about to say push a
pawn forward so this queen now no longer
attacking this pawn but maybe it will
slide down to the second rank prague
still has one active piece the black
queen very very active so magnus has to
be careful here uh still some work to be
done
it's all about this pawn though long
term watch out for alice the airport
just running up the board and promoting
later i mean even pushing it now is not
completely stupid and going queen a free
but you don't want to lose the pawn back
if you can help it um because a rook
rook behind the pawn is incredible it's
the best place to have your
have your rook uh and this kind of
ending is probably just winning for
white yeah this is basically like the
propeller you kind of have it behind and
it just propels the pawn forward and
blacks rook will be forced to be passive
stuck in front of the white pawn so even
losing a pawn a queen trade would still
be good for white magnus would be
desperate to get the queens off right
now he just has to be slightly careful
of these pawns aha okay well this game
it's definitely heating up the first
game in the match between magnus carlsen
and
the other matches going on for his games
bar is slightly over to
liam le side in his match first game
against eric hanson it's looking uh
good also for young christophe duda the
bar over to his side against
shakriyad mamdiarov duda has won two
matches in a row and the bar just went
down a little bit giri and the jordan
van forest the two dutchmen are also
playing each other today
and
if you're watching us on twitch
there's actually a very cool feature you
can now have a command center you can
basically design this the show yourself
and you can have up all the games if you
want to two games you can decide
yourself it's a very cool feature
command center on twitch to follow all
the chess moves if you want to we are
focusing today on pragnanda against
magnus carlsen and we did have another
move we did have another move and it's
one of the moves or one of the ideas we
mentioned just a moment ago white's
queen now on a great square she protects
her pawn uh on the b file white's pawns
now untouchable and she also attacks one
of black's pawns and wow prague just
giving away another pawn potentially
he's just activated his rook maybe amy
to bring his rook down to the bottom of
the board start checking the white king
um also maybe the black rook will join
the queen on the second rank some real
targets there
really interesting decision by prague
there i like it though not materialistic
he's already one pawn down he's happy to
go two pawns down as long as he gets his
rook active so a very mature decision
from prague he's doing what he can what
he has to do it's a very practical move
yeah i call this mode hustle mode
get active
you know pose your opponent some
problems it's a great way to defend and
uh it's not easy actually for magnus i
mean i was thinking what would i play
here is white not quite sure whether you
kind of allow the rook trade and he has
allowed the rogue trade okay
he's going to bank everything on this uh
queen and pawn ending and there will be
all about king safety so two moves now
for prague is he going to bring the
black rook down the whole way to the
bottom of the board trade-off rooks as
we may be expecting or is he going to
bring the black rook to the second rank
just uh line up the black queen and rook
together
start munching on some pawns maybe it's
a big big decision he's clicked on his
rook he's gonna bring it the whole way
down and give a check uh he's about to
play that one minute now on the clock
for prague and look at that he pre-moved
so he knew that the rooks would
disappear and very quickly instantly he
just took the rook back took a pawn with
the black queen because white's moves
were forced as well i mean you were
talking about the aim chess endings
we might see it now might have been so
uh this is we're into the ending with uh
magnus obviously having the pawn
advantage but he he's so i mean
magnus is very good at every ending the
queen endings particularly he seems to
excel in and it's all about who has the
past pawn in queen endings it's not
necessarily who's even material up who
who has the pawn which is easier to push
together and the board and king's safety
and that's where magnus is going to be
let down here because his king is
actually much more exposed than the
black king giving uh well giving uh uh
prague many chances of some perpetual
check here yeah that's the thing we talk
about past pawns white has why it's been
greedy white has three connected
passports black has no past pawns at all
uh so black's three versus one advantage
is actually quite hard to push but yeah
as you mentioned simon there's a direct
threat against the white king
and uh he has to stop this there's
actually two threats in the position uh
ivanko do you think he can stop them
both queen takes pawn is obviously one
but the bigger threat for example if
white saves his pawns is actually to
make a draw immediately this is how open
the king is this is a check the white
king goes back another check the white
king goes forward another check and
there's nowhere to hide for this king so
magnus okay by checking himself he's
gained a bit of time he's uh checked a
bit with the white queen now and he's
hoping to force the black king out into
the open
that has happened wow whose king is
weaker now big big question and magnus
he's pushed his pawn forward because wow
this is really clever if the queen
checks now there's no continuing of the
checks on this square because white's
queen actually guards that key square at
the bottom of the board magnus's king at
least temporarily is safe but can prague
now just take the apron yes
kyle nice one i think
he might well do that and uh i think two
options here you either take this pawn
or maybe you go to check on this square
so diagonal checks are often very very
effective in queen end games they're
harder to block somehow diagonal checks
and still some work to be done for white
to get his king to safety maybe the king
will retreat another check here hitting
this king hitting the pawn
prague still has some chances his queen
is so active and white's king is so out
in the open i have a suspicion we might
see a magnus try a king run yeah and uh
king is going to try to find some safety
on the left side of the board very close
to
his own queen and then doing two jobs
both hiding the pawns over the board and
also being protected yep
and uh okay well this is the issue bragg
obviously has to keep on checking
yeah big trap in the position uh if
queen takes pawn now then there would
have been a queen check a queen trade
will win for white because this pawn is
free to run down and promote so as you
might mentioned you have to keep
checking and uh that's what prague is
doing current position is still this one
where is white's king gonna hide it's
not so easy it's gonna hide up the board
maybe you have to be careful of counter
checks as well in these end games if you
check on the wrong square i said
diaconal checks are good but sometimes
they aren't because now white could
block the check with a check of his own
and uh the queen's come off and white
wins so prague has to be really really
careful right now
interesting and
in these so the kings
a big factor here in these queen end
games
will you want to use your king actively
or do you just want to protect it active
is good as long as you can block the
checks later so white's king if he could
uh pick up his own king magnus and kind
of put it on the left side with all his
pawns then actually not only is the king
active but it has shelter and oh prag
retreating the black king
is that a bad move yeah not a good sign
at least but it's getting out of the way
of any potential checks so this is a
valuable tempo that's true
um but he you know prague doesn't have
too much time on the clock he's under a
minute so he has to take some really
pragmatic decisions and there you can
see pragmatic i like it
very cleverly
of course she meant to say it
pragmatic prague i mean
that was sharp yeah good stuff must have
prepared that before no i didn't
actually
um yeah okay sorry
but don't say sorry it was a very
pragmatical decision
[Laughter]
here we go
in practice
okay so four minutes plays one minute
magnus also with the pawn advantage oh
it feels like he should win this one i
just remember so many examples off the
top of my head of magnus winning engage
like this there was also a very similar
endgame to this in the world
championship match uh that uh magnus won
against napoliacci that one was even
more simple he had even more extra pawns
but
just like that occasion he had extra
pawns on this side of the board and his
king was a bit open and he managed to
kind of combine he managed to run with
his king to the safe squares now he's
blocking checks with the white queen now
it's time for prague to get greedy and
grab some pawns maybe
you might not get another chance so is
prague going to give a check with the
black queen or is he going to start
munching on those white horns
funny thing is if he munches the pawn
it's actually equal material
so they do only have three pawns each so
people might be thinking well that's
okay but again it comes down to the past
pawns and white's pawns are so much
further advanced and they're not
obstructed at all all the blacks pawns
are actually obstructed by this one
little guy and also the king so this is
this is the real danger in the position
but he has grabbed the pawn and now
magnus is going to improve his queen and
the winning idea is to sort of improve
your queen and then push the pawn
get out of the checks and keep repeating
that process um and i think even you've
mentioned the white king might run its
way all over to the queen side at some
point in it and hide in front of its own
pawns
it has to it has to be careful when it
makes its journey to the i was going to
say to the east i don't know whether
it's too easy
never eat shredded wheat wheat west west
yes
i love that that's how i remembered uh
north west south indonesia never eats
shredded wheat yes exactly english
school kid thing i think elephant slurp
water yes
[Laughter]
yeah i mean while the pawns are running
the checks are coming though prague has
to give the correct check
and yeah you guys are right the king is
running to the west that way okay black
stops the king from running actually for
now but the king runs the other
direction and it's gonna be hard to kind
of
pin down that white king because if you
check it in the wrong direction it's
kind of gonna
hint that it's going both ways and you
can't stop it going both ways
you have to make sure that you force it
in the right direction and proud prague
has actually set up a really nasty
threat that's actually a checkmate
threat in two moves on the board i'm not
sure it's a great move but uh if it's
black's turn right now if magnus just
forgets and pushes one of the white
pawns prague is gonna
he's gonna bring the queen to the f4
square black's queen check the white
king into the corner and then he's gonna
trap it checkmate it maybe we can show
this on the board
checkmate does end the game and this is
why you always have to remember your
opponent's ideas black has just pushed
his pawn if white gets greedy uh gets
too ambitious and pushes his pawns
forward this is a check the king is
forced into the corner and then
checkmate the king is trapped on its own
and magnus actually stops that this is
why i wasn't sure it's a good move he
takes a pawn and covers the key square
black's queen can't use this square to
check where does he put his king now you
can still fall into it that would be i
mean you know it has been seen before by
strong players yeah you've got to be
really careful putting the king on the
wrong square this would not be good you
can't put your king this way either
because you walk into a skewer
when the king moves the white queen
drops next move uh so yeah where's
magnus going is he going this way or is
he going up the board up the board is
really really brave but it
wow yeah this pawn drops you'll write
your anchor checking this direction and
also getting rid of all of white's pawns
on this left side of the board this
would force a draw immediately how does
it get out of this this is a this is
process of elimination he has to step
back
oh no he can block with his queen he
found the best move so we see stockfish
there he had to block with the white
queen to win this one wasn't obvious but
magnus still has the advantage the only
move to save uh his advantage there
let's go back to the players because
it's uh yeah really heating up prague
defending like a tiger here and now it's
all about the a pawn then for minus yes
it's all about that one lone remaining
pawn either alice is going to become a
queen
or prague will save the game yeah
i mean it's so tense and these queen
endings are actually incredibly
complicated and like you say it's all
about promoting those past pawns and at
the same time you've got to
simultaneously make sure that your king
always has a safe place to hide or a
journey you can can take without getting
checked into
perpetuity just trying out a word from
bridget jones
and
yeah really key moment again magnus has
to be really careful you don't want to
put your king on the wrong square
otherwise you're walking to checkmate uh
also you can't block with the white
queen now because black's queen will go
back and pick up that white a pawn so
you can't block anymore you have to run
away but where do you run to oh
did it draw it's not amazing now
i think you have to go
i was going to say either up the board
or slightly towards the center but both
had their downfalls there it'd be
incredible if he draws this i mean
you know he's really been struggling
here and maybe he is proving his his
in-game skills just up there because
defending endings is i think much harder
than actually winning them uh and he's
giving it a really good go here that's
gonna said ten seconds 10 seconds yeah
it's easy to go wrong and the queen
gives a check and i'm wondering okay
magnus still has to be incredibly
careful where he puts the king he puts
it on the wrong square anywhere along
the h line he's going to get checkmated
so that's why he grabs a pawn he
eliminates one of black's attackers
actually that black pawn but now
suddenly it's gonna be uh okay i was
gonna say maybe one pawn versus one pawn
but no there's a trap in the position if
prague gets greedy here and captures
this white pawn on the g2 square white
will give a check any trade of queens
will win for white because white's
remaining a pawn will promote so prague
has to be really careful he has to keep
checking in nine seconds he made that
move
i mean
he's he's doing a brilliant job but i
mean it is magnus carlsen he's still a
pawn down in a short time this cross
check you mentioned here um where you
meet a check with the check to exchange
queens is again a very common tactic in
these endings to get the queens off the
board well worth looking out for uh how
does magnus now push the pawn because
this is a problem magnus has got to push
the pawn and guard his king from any
perpetual checks which will result in a
draw
yeah and actually just a couple of
months ago i had a very similar end game
against nils grandelias where i was on
the defensive side and i just like prac
i was on a few seconds every time and
you just have to go for these checks
every time uh every turn you just have
to hope that your opponent walks into
them and what a move by magnus crazy
stopping any checks black's queen was
actually threatening to come down and
check the white king from behind on the
h line that's been blocked and if
black's queen comes down and takes this
white pawn that has just moved white's
queen will shuffle across
crosstalk
and trade queens sorry i'm saying that
because he made that move with two
seconds to spare that's incredible
yeah if she doesn't beat him the clock
might do yeah yeah i mean g3 was such a
nasty move to face because again in
these situations where you're short of
time it's easier to rack to forcing
moves if your checks you move your king
but if your opponent plays a quiet move
like magnus did you like hang on a
minute i'm not prepared for this what do
i play and he found this move probably a
very good move trying to bring the queen
into the corner and keep those checks
coming um i'm just looking at the camera
i'm just looking at a prague sitting
there in this chair he looks so calm
living on the edge those players look
very calm and uh wow okay prank just
lifting his king up the board there so
still not easy for white's king to find
safety the black queen has some ideas of
checking okay magnus gains a bit of time
as well by forcing the black king away
centralizing the white queen this is
what magnus is so good at putting his
queen on one of the four central squares
he's maybe the best queen and game
player i've ever seen just because he
finds ways to do that but gains time in
the process and the white queen on this
square not only will she guard the white
king from checks on the dark squares but
she will also uh kind of threaten checks
herself so right now i'm expecting
magnus at some point to start trying to
bring the white king over to that side
of the board to support its pawn it's
not an easy journey it's kind of full of
traps it's a bit of a maze but if
white's king can somehow eventually
start walking over to
kind of help alice the a pawn out then
magnus should win i mean i think it's a
good rule in these positions like if
you're trying to advance to what i was
going to say keep your queen in the
middle of the board
which magnus is keeping in that area
because queen in the middle of the board
it controls so many squares and that's
just a good rule and he's put it on
another square in the middle of the
board and this also makes sense because
now he's got options to uh bring the
queen zooming over uh in front of the
white pawn and one square where the
white pawn can't guard it so uh again
yeah like you said david very clever
play with the queen here yeah and uh
prague also doing a very good thing
actually uh one thing i well the
elevation bar not liking it but one
thing i was going to say i've learnt
from queen engames is the defending side
should always put the king in the corner
put your own king near the corner just
in case there are stalemate ideas you
don't want your own king out in the open
where it can get checked from every
angle every direction you want your own
king in the corner so prague he's put
his the black king as close to that
corner square as possible just in case
and it's up to magnus again to find that
winning plan
and magnus now under 30 seconds on the
clock and he will be looking at all the
checks trying to find
a great uh kind of check that will
potentially swap off queens if he's not
that do not if he's not doing that then
obviously he needs to get his king to
safety
okay he moves his queen forward offering
a trade
yeah this is quite logical isn't it
because now the white king can make a
long journey all the way to the left i
feel and it's going that way because you
can hide now in front of the queen and
the pawns so you've got two shields
there uh it doesn't really matter about
your pawn uh
which black can now take that is an
irrelevant pawn because the white pawn
it's all about can white queen that one
is far advanced and i think this plan i
really like this plan now it's looking
so good for magnus that king simply
going to the left-hand side of the board
hiding and then pushing yeah and this is
almost identical now to my game against
nils grandelias except white's pawn
disappeared uh in that game and as black
i had another pawn guarding the black
cage
it was a draw but even that was shaky so
that was a much better version of this
end game for prague and i managed to
hold it but this one isn't possible to
hold and um wow magnus what a move he's
given up alice the a pawn because white
can go for checkmate if black now gets
greedy and captures that pawn that's
incredible i mean we have to show this
you have to show it yeah it's an amazing
idea from magnus carlson here um just on
the last move he blocked with the white
queen this check if black plays queen
takes pawn then suddenly it's just
checkmate uh one check from the diagonal
wherever the king goes another check and
the king gets trapped at its home here
and uh this one would have won the game
so that's why prague couldn't grab the
pawn instead if we catch up with the
current position this guy is just going
to win now uh it's a matter of time
magnus dancing with his king towards
that pawn the king is just going to
zigzag its way to support its push to
the promotion square
great technique it looks like prague
he's defended he's done everything he
could but magnus just too strong
and uh it's a matter of time before this
pawn pushes forward it's incredible to
see the king
all the way over to the other side
that's a long journey for the white king
sound of the match
yeah definitely
yeah he's done a lot of work hasn't he
in this game and it's it's now just
going to hide over there and as you say
this should be game over really what a
game to start us off with he's gone
right down to the right down to the wire
magnus of course have the white pieces
had the advantage had a small advantage
but the way that prague has been
fighting is a great sign and he's got
white in the next game i know i expect
him to lose his one we're not sure but
will he be able to bounce back with the
advantage of the white pieces
wow
yeah i mean uh kudos to both players
it's been a really tight battle here uh
magnus now found a safe square for his
king in front of his pawn but the king
doesn't necessarily want to stay there
for too long that pawn is the potential
winner so still some work for magnus to
do to kind of uh escape from in front of
his own pawn this is a check the white
king will retreat now or go up into the
corner and okay diagonal checks still
making it hard prague
the queen trying to make the checking
box as big as possible as we call it
just trying to check from as far away as
possible to stop any cross-checks any
blocks but white's king now continuing
his dance
yes i mean it's it's basically the
position of the black king is probably
one of the worst positions it can be in
here if you could pick the black king up
and put it in another corner it'd be so
much better because there's all these
cross checks we've talked about where
white can at some point block a check
with a check and swap the queens off
and it's just this black king is in a
terrible situation where it is and
that's why they say you know put if you
want to win this a queen and pawn ending
you should put your king opposite the
enemy king
it's a good attacking
device okay we see magnus blocking a
check and offering a trade of queens and
pragnanda just has to keep on checking
yeah okay white's gone in front of his
own pawn again and now once more you
cannot take white pawn the queen the
pawn next to black's queen is poisoned
if you take that pawn white's queen will
actually go up to the top of the board
and trade off the queens you really have
to be so careful where you put your own
queen
uh magnus continues to set these traps
for his young opponent and okay just a
kind of waiting move there by prague
you guys are right if those two pawns
didn't exist on the right half of the
board if black's king was down in the
bottom right corner maybe this is the
best place to have it in the bottom
right corner i'm over trying to defend
this ending without those pawns and if
the black king can get out the way you
can keep checking but the problem here
is for example even now if black checks
the king next to the king you do this
cross thing okay so he's trying to get
his king out to a better square
um
he's still being really resourceful uh
to just stay alive you certainly should
not resign this position because you've
always got a chance of getting a
perpetual why resign when you've got any
chance at all that'd be crazy especially
with a time situation
and uh meanwhile the evaluation bar has
shot up so that means white can probably
make a new queen by force i'm expecting
white's pawn to push forward here magnus
just checking that that uh doesn't box
in the white king for example but
it looks fine you can push your white
pawn forward i don't think black has
sufficient checks available now um again
you have to be really careful white's
queen can block any potential checks
here and when the white king gets a
moment to start running out of uh kind
of way of its own pawn as we go now the
white pawn will soon promote yeah and i
think the queen was gonna the king sorry
is gonna hide itself on the eighth row
uh on the c8 square
and it has it's got to that square and
this is where yeah again
i mean they're going to run out checks
there you've got one check the king
steps forwards and you've got this cross
check so yeah the queen and king
the black queen and king are just
somehow not working well together like
you say it's in the way
plus 61 now for the evaluation bar for
white that means the new queen is coming
prague is going to resign any moment see
it there it goes it's over the king
magnus crossing using his king to strike
first in the battle with pragnanda
magnus with